HV11, a monumental work by Nicolas Sanhes
For 15 years Nicolas Sanhes has produced works
in increasingly important formats.
The control of dimensions and technical constraints
allows him to complete his first public orders
for the cities of Trappes in 2007
and Montélimar the following year, in France.
Built for the city of Valenciennes, HV11 in 2013
will be his most complex work to date.
Today we have the receipt of steel
raw material to make the sculpture
of the public order of Valenciennes
which will hopefully be delivered in June,
around June 2013.
The project was born a long time ago
now it's almost the end, we could say
because this is the final realization
it's the construction of the work
the project is already sold, it has already been studied.
It's a project I've been working on for a year and a half.
It always takes a long time to complete public orders
because there is the preliminary study, the meeting
there is site analysis
then reflection in the workshop to propose a piece for the site
acceptance of the work by the municipal council
and then the realization that starts today.
Valenciennes has the distinction of being
a city whose industrial memory
was very strong in terms of steel
and when the city was renovated
by one of the very famous mayors
they decided to conduct a cultural policy
very strong to energize the city
and attract new residents
and contemporary art has been one of the vectors of this renewal.
So they chose an artistic line
who is the monumental sculpture and the geometric sculpture.
Valenciennes has this policy of acquiring works
or loan of works
and it is within this framework through my work
that I was approached by the deputy mayor
to propose a project.
This is the work that brought me to Valenciennes.
The Valenciennes order is an order that I find great
because I was invited by the city to come.
The Deputy Mayor for Culture received me on a Sunday afternoon
we went around the city
explaining to me all the orders they had placed
it goes from Mark di Suvero to Norman Dilworth
all great sculptors.
And then I was asked to choose a place
and it was me who, after wandering around, chose a space
that suited what I wanted to do
I made the offer to them
and that was exactly where they wanted me to be.
So finally there is no moment when there is something imposed.
There is really the concern of giving to the artist
the ability to do what he wants and where he wants.
And that is very important because this kind of thing is quite rare.
I had no plan. I took into account the physiognomy of the place
which is a big place
which acts as both a roundabout
but that the public can cross
who is on the city tour
whose visions are ascending or descending at times
and circular
so I took into account these physical parameters of space
to suggest a piece
but as my work is very complicated, in the monumentality
because the lines are too complex to be moved
for example I will have to cut the structure
to take it out of the workshop and put it outside
so it's very complicated
so I gave myself a lot of time
I asked them 6 months to quietly think about this project
and give them a definitive plan.
That's what I did.
I worked calmly
having all the files in front of me
every day in my workshop
to watch, to soak up
and things fell into place quietly
until I get the idea exactly
what I'm looking for Valenciennes.
After I refined the project,
I reworked it and brought it.
747 kilos of flat irons!
Ok, thank you, see you next time!
And that's how it starts.
If I make a model like this
it's mainly to understand
the technical aspects and the resistances of the attachment points
that the sculpture will undergo
each line weighing almost a ton
it will hold only by an assembly
it's almost 800 kilos
and it's a fiftieth model.
There are several angles of view
it's fun to watch today
how the sculpture will be big
it is a ratio of scale.
The public should have this vision.
What I like is to work live
to be emotional
in this research
we make art not crafts
otherwise it becomes very complicated
if we make a small project and multiply it big ...
This is part of the work theme
on the rational side of work
but it is also necessary that the feeling, the emotion is there
so that afterwards we can find him in the piece,
that is very important.
I make lines for two or three weeks
and then I assemble
That's when the magic happens.
The sculpture will be 6 meters long
almost 6 meters side according to the points of view
4.5 meters as part of a parallelepiped, and 3 meters high.
It's structural steel beam
200 millimeters, called HEA, which will be fully closed.
Three steel lines that will play like this.
I will have to take it out of the workshop, so I will cut it.
Then we will have the problem of transportation
so it will definitely be overnight transportation
You have to pass Paris so there are huge constraints.
For example, the bridges in the north are lower than in the south.
There are a lot of constraints that you have to know too
when we do sculpture
that's the problem of the transporter
but it's better to have it in mind
there are these constraints.
Of course you have to make sure that the piece will hold
there is a ten year guarantee
there are also safety standards.
When I build a piece,
on the most stretched clothes rails
I plan an additional charge
in case there are five or six people climbing on it
to celebrate for example a French rugby victory,
you have to take that into account to prevent the sculpture from breaking
or overturns because that is my responsibility.
These are my assistants
I have one that wears and one that tilts
and then I just have to solder.
Even if it's big, monumental,
it is to the millimeter because
little by little at the end we can have
big differences in angle
and suddenly the piece would not be the same at all.
I use the green hoist to climb
and from it to tilt the degrees.
It is an awareness of space.
I am not in a hurry.
I'm enjoying this little moment
It allows me to think
to the whole piece and to work.
It is important. It brings a strong connection to make a play like that.
We say that we work for a space, a public space, for people ...
You have to appreciate that moment.
And it's just fun.
Here and there I am.
I use everything when I work
I use my tools of course
my body
my head of course
my hands but also my legs
it allows me to adjust
It holds
You shouldn't be exhausted on the job either
It always has to be fun
We must also respond to upcoming exhibitions
things to show up for
If I start sculpture today
I imagine it takes about three months of hard work
so I prefer at first
since winter is coming and the workshop is not heated
we will be able to cut steel, it will warm us
and as soon as the beautiful days arrive
we can start finishing and painting
I also manage my work in the workshop
depending on weather conditions!
I wanted to gain a millimeter ...
it's done
Hold left
take exit 21bis towards Valenciennes center
Today we are going to make the first location
with technical services, on site
and adjust with the mason the implantation of the sculpture
In my opinion, this is what we will see with the crane operator earlier
here we will cut traffic during the night
we will put the truck here
that's what i would do
the truck here, the crane on one side or the other whatever
we take the elements and bring them to the center
or we will put the crane there, and the truck can leave
and then we can work quietly
without stopping the traffic.
The approach with Nicolas is original
because it's the first time the city
in the field of geometric abstraction
place an order.
Nicolas is in a way a successor to Bernar Venet
since Bernar Venet who met Nicolas
in Valenciennes which I am very proud of
was very positive about Nicolas' work.
We actually went up in 2011
with 32 municipalities in the region
a festival which was called "rives, dérives"
along the river Escaut,
in cities crossed by the river
and Nicolas exhibited in a town near Valenciennes
to see his work which attracted me a lot
and then we progressed together.
I told him about one of the problems facing me
which was to find a work for one of the city roundabouts
a real work, not what we usually find
on many roundabouts in France.
and he says to me : "I'm going to think"
it was strictly without obligation
and so he thought about it a lot,
it's a complex roundabout
with a lot of roads coming over it
important routes, secondary routes
the city's public park which overlooks this roundabout
and one day he sent me a file
extremely argued and worked
I presented this work to the mayor
and everyone was convinced
I don't know how it goes in the other cities
in Valenciennes it's totally subjective
A work of art is not a brick of soup
although there can be subjectivity in the soup brick too!
it is a heart stroke for a work and also for the artist
that's how the operations were done
all those that are done in Valenciennes
especially in contemporary art since 2007
with a principle which is geometric abstraction
which is the only caudine fork, with the humanity of the artist
that is imposed to succeed in doing something in this city.
There is a little handling to do
so I will bring the tackles it takes to properly focus the elements
so unload the truck, bring the central part in the middle on the stud,
the other two lines and we assemble
It's not very complicated!
Here it is simple, the feeling went well
it will be OK, it will be OK!
This starts from a historical aspect since
it is the city of Jean-Baptiste Carpeaux.
It is the city of France which had the greatest number of Rome prize
more than Paris, about fifty, and a majority of sculptors
So the initial idea was to say that all the sculptors
who had a Rome prize
be present in their city whether we like them or not
The idea was born that the city is a temporary exhibition gallery
and to propose to artists to deposit a work
for two or three years
we had deposits like that and then we had meetings
and then there are people who are more affordable,
who have been offered to buy
We are in the gardens of the museum of fine arts of Valenciennes
We are next to a work by an English sculptor called Norman Dilworth
a work called "1, 2, 3, 4, 5".
It's a piece that I really like.
There are a lot of people who don't go to the museum.
I believe that for sculpture there is nothing better than the street.
You just have to walk through the streets of the city to see
how there are starting to be works everywhere
We will continue to develop it,
replace those who leave
and also acquire it because artists are never so important
that when they are alive
it's good to participate in the development of their career
and allow them to live simply
I am in front of the "grande blanche"
It's a loan to the city that I installed in September
which I will remove when I have installed the sculpture in Place Cardon.
It's a loan.
It is so that the public of Valenciennes
get a little familiar with the geometry of my work.
It must have been pretty like that in white
snow, white sculpture ...
It will need a little cleaning in the spring
this is normal, white is more messy than raw steel.
I'm glad it is there
it works both in winter and summer.
in summer it is really covered by the big trees which dominate it
and that closes the space
and the location with the architecture of the museum suits it well.
It is a loan that I am glad to have made.
On the deposit of the "grande blanche"
the feedback is really very favorable.
There are always people who don't like
Fortunately! I used to say
that unanimity scares me very much in this matter
I prefer people to oppose it,
find it not okay at all and argue
rather than indifference.
Here I really feel that it is going well
There are always people to tell you that it's very good
We're not completely blind or fooled but
I have my antennas, my network,
which tells me that people generally like it
and there's an impatience to see the next one arrive.
Nicolas will improve the lives of Valenciennes for eternity
finally our eternity since it is obvious
that HV11 is going to have a higher eternity
to Nicolas and to me, I believe.
The idea of ​​this temporary installation is to see
the amplitude that the center line of the sculpture
occupies in portal space
to calculate exactly the cuts I will have to make
on the final piece.
The latitude that I have between the sides of the portal
and the line is 20 centimeters.
That means that when I'm going to assemble the structure definitively
I will have to stand above this line of 20 centimeters maximum
and there I can go out
if I exceed I will have to break the gate.
The cut I'm going to make here must be equal to the one above
in this part there and in that one.
after when i position the piece
i'm sure to fall wherever i want
and we see whether to remove material or add more
for example there I need to add 3 centimeters
3 centimeters is missing ... it happens!
I'm trying to set up the plate
which will hold the two lines together
It will be completely in space.
It must hold!
I know that this central part
it is the body of the sculpture.
All the tension will end up here with the third line
which I will position next week.
By putting the bolts I increase the rigidity
These are bolts that support 3 tonnes each
So here we are on 12 tonnes of pressure
so it risks absolutely nothing.
The work is done empirically
but I'm starting to control the material
I know where to make it more solid
when I work on assemblies.
but there is always a tension
When we do the piece, the distance is missing
which is acquired with the maturity of the work
After this piece I can go even further
in the work, the design of the pieces
I can now do removable things
so far this has not been the case.
see even bigger
I can make it twice as big
To give an idea it's 12 meters long and 6 meters high
which is roughly the height of the workshop volume
and the beam 400 by 400
it makes squares like that
It's not to be megalomaniac
is to go further in sculptural research
to stretch these lines in space
and relate sculpture to architecture
because here the sculpture looks big
but in the urban space it will be smaller
but it is sized in relation to the space that will accommodate it
if I put it next to a building in Shanghai it is ridiculous
We must also have this awareness that in work
you have to be able to develop in the long term
it goes through workshop work,
by solving technical problems.
It's always a challenge, a victory over yourself
when I spend weeks or months alone in my workshop
I learn something even if I am alone
It's pushing your limits and also bringing dreams
to myself and to those who will look at the sculpture
saying to himself : "how does it hold?"
It is this notion of freedom that is important
and it is also to say :
"no i don't let myself be dictated by the material!"
My sculpture is a formal matter
so I have to bring the material to my intention
it's not the opposite!
Material has limits
but we can overcome the limits.
By looking at how the material plays
where it spins, where it works
There are zones where it works more than others
it is by observing
we realize if it twists, if it works
so we strengthen
It's engineering work that also
part of the sculptor's work
Technicality is important in artistic work
maybe some contemporary artists forget it
When I started making the pieces of wood
I made them here or I worked outside
This is where the first tensions occured
then I developed them in a more emancipated way
in the large workshop
This is where it started
I use it for all the management of my work
drawing and recently painting
the painting came at the same time
that Valenciennes sculpture
It was a need to keep an intellectual freshness
in the hard work of the workshop
When I started HV11 I had a plan on this table
with photos of the site
after I made a file
The idea is to wonder how we apprehend this place
how we get there, how we live it and how we get out of it.
These are circular movements due to its shape
it's almost an octagon
The idea is that we also have in sculpture this movement
that I managed to give thanks
at the inclination of the lines in space.
and that the motorist or the pedestrian goes around the place
have this revolving vision
The computer is a tool just like the welding machine
When I work on a project
I use the photo a lot, the work of the workshop
then I make computer generated images
so that sponsors have a vision
very precise of the final rendering
This is important, it allows me
to adjust the size of the piece
We're going to have a big white rectangle
on which the sculpture will be placed.
When I'm in the workshop I feel good, I am out of time.
Even in contemporary art there are many artists
who have an approach where the works are too imprinted
of the world we live in
too loaded with technology
I try to be out of it
Distance seem necessary to me
to understand the world we are in.
It's 5 months of work
with very different phases
phases of concern over the completion of the project
of combat, of duration in time
to keep the intellectual freshness of artistic work
in the complexity of the work
and the physical difficulty of the work.
This sculpture represents a certain passage
it has a different conception of space
than the previous pieces
it was complex to maintain the mass of the sculpture
because some lines weigh more than 1.5 tonnes
it was a major technical challenge
which makes me think that I can go even further
in the tension of the lines and the design of the sculpture.
It is a passage which opens on another stage
higher, more ambitious, just for fun
to go further in research,
in the stake, in the risk taking
which is important to me if we want to move forward in life.
I leave time to time
if things have to come it's good,
otherwise it doesn't matter
What is important is that every day that I am there
I take pleasure in doing this.
No, no, wait, we're not going!
I'm going to push with Eric
It is not the largest.
The largest to date is that
of Montélimar which is 7 meters high
This one is more complex
than that of Montélimar which has more open lines
Here they are more closed so we increase the weight
The spatial design is not the same.
It is the most complex.
This work was important
because it allowed me to open the sculpture
My previous works are smaller.
The welds were sufficient
so that the lines hold.
When we have more range, we know that steel
is flexible, it bends
it is therefore necessary to reinforce in specific zones
so that it does not break later.
I'm happy with this piece,
it lets me predict an opening
greater in my work
and greater risk-taking
There are no limits, except those we set for ourselves.
I don't give myself limits.
It's not a heartbreak at all,
it's even a certain pleasure
to share it with the public
I'm waiting for this pretty nice moment
which will fill 5 months of solitude in the workshop
and I have other projects pending
I can't wait to start another piece
to take further risk-taking
of the arrangement of lines in space.
You have to think that the sculpture
is made for a specific site
initially it has a circular design
you get the impression of movement
when you discover the sculpture
as if we were being told a story
going around the piece.
We create the piece according to the place
precisely so that it is just in relation to space.
It shouldn't be too big
Do not impose things
I'm here to do the fairest thing possible.
There you will need a small chamfer
The solder point allows me to adjust the top element.
This will make a benchmark.
So we'll put a punch.
No problem.
Thank you!
We would have to put two straps
that we pass on each side. We raise ...
Then we put it there.
I saw the place, I will have the answer when the sculpture is placed
I will see if I have captured the space
if the device of its positioning in the space of the roundabout
is fair compared to the visions I had of sculpture
All of this was imagined from a plan
from computer generated images
I hope my feeling of the place will be right.
I will see if it is fair in its dimensions
Maybe it will be a little small or its real size
Next time we will try to do it differently
but i think it will be good
Its good ?
Its good ? It bolts ... great!
Now we put the other part
then we adjust well relative to the center
we adjust the concrete plates well
then we weld and it's over.
We are on schedule so we have time.
You have to lower!
What is important is the relationship that there can be
between the lines, and their spatial arrangements
They must be close enough
not too far apart otherwise the sculpture lacks coherence
it's trying to find a happy medium.
The lines get married, they tie together on points
these are fragile points
it just rests on angles.
The idea is that so that things
where human beings can exist
in any case live normally
or at least with a notion of balance
it is this distance that we put between each other
so that things are fair.
I don't invent anything, I just look at the world
and I try to do with my feelings, with my story
to put these ideas into place in a formal proposal.
In daily work a logical sequence is established
the concepts are in place
as well as a certain idea of ​​geometry.
This is the result of simple observations,
daily, over time
that make things valuable,
an existence, a thickness
and develop afterwards.
Yes, above and below ...
If tonight I can put them down it's perfect
after tomorrow i paint
and I would see for the gravel
I have the crane for another two hours
so we will not hurry, the check is the same!
I have the big grinder it will go faster, I will make it!
Make the big one I will finish
We remove!
Are we removing or lifting?
We remove, we remove!
We dismantle!
Two more hours of work to finish the turntables
we will have to work hard on it.
I will resin tomorrow if necessary.
Philippe thank you very much! See you next time.
Eric thank you!
We're going to lift it, ok?
It says "HV11", then he will explain to you what it is
"H" is the first letter of the material, "HEA"
"V" is the initial of Valenciennes
"11" is the year of meeting
It's really simple!
We see those who have read the text or not!
We understood why, that's it!
Did you design it according to space?
Yes
Of course
You have to understand the place
You have to feel it.
It is designed to guide the movement of the square.
In sculpture it has to hold,
it is the characteristic of sculpture
but it has to hold physically and plastically.
So there is a double issue like that.
It is very important to be able to link these two aspects
without it being immediately noticeable.
Line adjustment,
this relationship we can have with the piece
this emotion that we can have
because we don't really know how it holds.
It's the magic of sculpture
to have a shape like that in space.